[Musique]
l'objectif c'est vraiment de
sensibiliser beaucoup de public c'est de
sensibiliser
les élus les personnes qui travaillent
la mairie le public plus quoi les
enfants les personnes qui sont peut-être
pas au courant et puis aussi les
personnes qui vivent cette situation de
handicap soit puisqu'elles sont tels
même en situation dans les gares ou soit
puisqu'elles sont des dents et il y en a
vraiment beaucoup donc c'était pour que
les gens soient davantage sensibilisés
et éventuellement qu'ils veuillent
pourquoi pas s'engager
on a deux évènements mardi le mardi soir
17h on a une conférence sur l'épilepsie
et comment est ce que on accompagne
surtout les enfants ou les personnes qui
souffrent d'épilepsie dans les écoles
dans la situation sociale donc on a ça
on a aussi mardi matin et s'asseoir près
de dimanche lors du grand week end un
théâtre forum alors le sujet du théâtre
forum c'est comment insérer ces
personnes qui sont en situation
d'handicap dans le milieu professionnel
le 13 samedi on va passer le film
passionnant le tertre de buc à 20h30 on
a aussi le dimanche donc c'est le
dimanche qui la grande journée une
partie aussi au gymnase où il y aura des
associations sportives et autres qui
vont présenter et puis le dimanche je me
permets parce que je prends le document
j'ai pas tout en tête mais ils vont être
des expositions des animations
des conférences des débats